[SQUEAKING]
[CLICKING]
[RUSTLING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: All right.
I'm going to get started.
This is lecture 19, of 14.13.
I'm going to finish up
some of what we discussed
last time on gender
discrimination and identity
And then we're going to talk
about nudges and default
effects.
So let me sort of fairly
quickly go through the remaining
slides of lecture 18, and then
move to the lecture slides.
So remember, we talked
last time about the study
by Bertrand et al. about
gender identity norms,
where we talked about because--
so the authors argue there's
this norm that some men
perceive-- and perhaps
even some women--
that men should be earning
more than their wives.
There's this cliff-- this
missing mass of households
or couples in the US.
We talked about different
reasons for that.
Missing couples that don't
form in the first place.
Such marriages and couples
are less happy and stable,
so they end up in divorce.
And there's also,
even for existing
couples that form, whether
the wife or the woman
has more earnings potential.
In some cases, at
least, women tend
to either work less few hours,
and therefore perhaps that
was promoted and the like.
And in addition, they
might be involved in more
nonmarket and childcare work.
It's called the second shift.
They have to do more work
because the husband is very
unhappy about her earning more.
Which then, of course,
holds potentially
the wife back at her work.
Now, somebody was
asking last time--
I believe Justin or
others-- about the arrival
of children and the gender gap.
So there's quite a few
studies like this one.
So out of this here,
which is the study
by Kleven et al. in Denmark.
And these studies
essentially show
there is a substantial what they
call child penalty for women,
which is when you look at
men's and women's earnings.
On the left-hand side, there's
a figure shows earnings.
This is yearly data over time.
On the right-hand side,
you see hours worked.
Similarly, you see productivity.
But essentially, you tend
to see is that for men--
this is the gray
bar here on top--
you see essentially
before the child is born,
you match men and women to
have sort of similar earnings,
the trajectory would
look very similar.
And then, for men,
perhaps there's
a slight decline or no further
for the increase over time.
But for women, there's a
clear drop in earnings.
And that drop persists
for many, many years.
So it's not just like
there's a year after birth,
there's lower earnings
for, on average, women.
But there's a
persistent gap overall
that has to be presumably
with some women
never returning back to work,
some women remaining part time,
just some women working a few
hours when they have children.
Notice that that's not
just about hours worked.
So when you look at
the earnings gap,
it's about something like 20%.
The long-run child
penalty here is like 20%.
It's also, for
hours worked, it's
something like 10%, which
must mean that there's
an additional 10% coming
from productivity or wages
conditional on hours worked.
So it's not only that women
are working fewer hours,
but they're also paid less
per hour, which presumably
is once people start working
few hours, take more breaks,
or just take a break
for a few years,
that they're getting less
promotions and so on.
And that sort of carries
through for a long time.
Now, interestingly, some of
these child penalties are
transmitted through
generations--
meaning from parents
to daughters--
suggesting that essentially,
in the same family
where there is child
penalties from the parents--
as in the woman that
is a childcare penalty
for the mother, the
daughter will also
be likely to have a
child penalty later on.
Like, 20, 30 years once
she's been actually working.
So there seems to be
something to do with the child
environment and gender
identity, which is the norm
that the woman is supposed
to take care of the children,
versus the husband is not.
And that seems to be sort of
permitted through generations
in the child environment.
Now, you might sort of say,
well, then, couldn't we
just do some policies that
support women or support
parents to help them deal
with children better?
And wouldn't that help?
And there's some policies
that people have done.
In particular, in academia,
you might say, well,
if a woman has a child or a
couple as a child in general,
that's surely a hint
to productivity.
And so therefore, one could
say, well, that's [INAUDIBLE]..
That's in fact what
people have been doing,
is sort of, let's stop people's
tenure clock which essentially
is an assistant professor.
People have something
like 7, 8, 9 years
to do this research
until tenure.
You might say, let's
give people another year
if they have a child.
Now, one proposal is to have
gender neutral clock stopping
policies.
Now, these policies are intended
to involve these gender neutral
policies, meaning that both
parents, regardless of who's
giving-- or not just
the person who's
giving birth, but also
the other person who's
taking care of the
child potentially
is getting an additional
year on the tenure clock.
So the intention is here in
particular to involve men more
in child care.
But you know, those
kinds of policies
tend to be not enforced,
and potentially
they might even enhance
gender inequality
if it's the case that both men
and women get another year.
But the man essentially
takes that as a year
off where you can do additional
work while the woman is back
taking care of the
household and the child.
Then, such policies in some
ways might make things worse.
And this is exactly
what some studies find,
is that these gender neutral
policies, in particular,
in economics.
There's also some examples
from other settings.
But essentially, introducing
such policies substantially
reduce female tenure rates while
increasing male tenure rates.
So here's a policy that
looks actually a good policy.
It's gender neutral and so on.
But in fact, it might not
be, depending on who takes
advantage of that
and who doesn't.
So it's a very tricky question
because some of these things
are not enforceable.
If instead you gave only these
tenure exemptions to women,
then you would get issues in
households, that then women
are sort of pushed out
of work, which in part I
think some of these
neutral tenure
clocks try to avoid
in the first place.
So it's not clear
what to do here.
But I think it's
important to understand
that some policies
that look like they
are in fact neutral or gender
neutral, they might in fact not
be.
Now, let me tell you what I [got
about one more paper related
to gender and the labor
market or identity,
which is very nice paper
by Bursztyn et al., which
asks the question whether women
avoid career enhancing actions
because these actions
signal undesirable traits.
So in particular,
women might be--
ambitious women
might be perceived
as not attractive partners
in the labor market,
in particular, in some settings
such as among MBA students.
And so, in particular, as
you might be familiar with,
there's lots of dating happening
among MBA students, where
people try to essentially find
partners or somebody to get
married to.
And it appears to be the case
that being ambitious or being
perhaps overly
ambitious is perceived
as negatively as an
undesirable trait
on the dating market for MBAs.
Now, what Bursztyn et al.
find-- and this is joint work
with Amanda Pallais and Thomas
Fujiwara they find that
unmarried and unmarried
female MBA students
perform similarly
when the performance is
unobserved by classmates.
So these are things like
exams, problem sets.
These are things that
only the professor sees,
but not necessarily
their classmates.
To here, male and--
sorry.
Unmarried and married female
MBA students do similarly
well when we compare them.
But unmarried women have
lower participation rates.
So these are
essentially things that,
do you say something in class?
And as you might know, in MBA
classes, in some, at least,
there's somebody sitting in
the back actually recording
each interaction, each
participation very carefully
so you know exactly who says
how many things and how often,
and so on.
So it seems to me
that unmarried women
tend to not want to look too
ambitious and too hard-working
in class.
Now, that's of course
only suggestive.
So then, they also
have a field experiment
where they ask people about
their desired salaries
and willingness to travel and
work long hours in real stakes
placement questioning.
So this essentially, at the
end, there's this placement,
there's these career fairs.
But people ask these
questions about,
what salary are you expecting?
Are you willing to
travel really far?
work long hours?
And so on.
And of course, these
questions all signal ambition.
And then, the really interesting
part of the experiment
is, then, they varied
whether this information is
perceived to be private.
So you just saying
it to a recruiter
but nobody else in your
class, or anybody else
might find out, versus whether
there some expectation of some
of their classmates
actually learning
about their preferences.
And what they find, then, is
that the single female students
report lower desired
salary, and willingness
to travel, and work hours--
and work long hours
when they think
that there's an expectation that
their classmates might find out
about it.
Which essentially
is to say, they
perceive it to be
costly for their class,
or their classmates find
out about their ambition.
Now, importantly, two
other things are also true.
One is for other groups.
So, other women that are
not single or for men.
Essentially, these responses
are unaffected by peer
observability.
And second, it seems
to be that what's
driving the observability
result is the observability
by single male peers.
So when other female students
or other non-single male peers
are potentially seeing these
answers, there's no effect.
But the effect's really coming
from other single male peers
potentially seeing it, which
is precisely what you expect
if you think having
ambition is potentially
a negative signal on
the dating market.
So that's another
sort of study showing
that these norms
or perceived norms
are really important, not just
in terms of punishing women
and in some ways
undeservedly for mistakes
as we saw in Heather
Sarson's paper,
but also by holding
women back by themselves.
These are single women who are
highly qualified MBA students
who are deliberately not as
ambitious and hard-working
as perhaps you might think
they would like to be--
which is what the private
responses suggest--
because there's a
penalty waiting for them,
or receive penalty coming
on the dating market.
Any questions about this?
So here's a question about,
can it be the opposite?
Better ask this in person.
It's a little bit hard
for me to follow the chat.
But can it be that
more confident women
tend to be married?
Yes.
In principle, yes.
But I think what we see
here in the experiment
is, notice that
what I was saying,
I was careful to say these
are about there's a perceived
penalty of being
overly ambitious.
There may well be for some
women, being very ambitious
and so on.
That's a very highly
desirable trait.
But it seems to be that
the perception, at least,
is that being highly ambitious
and so on is not desired.
So I think there's
another question
by Lucy about married
women compensating
for discrimination.
I think that's all.
There might be other
stuff going on.
But I think the key part
here is the variation
between private and public
among single female students.
So when they are
asking in private,
they are saying essentially
they want higher salaries.
When they're asking in public
for higher salaries and they're
willing to work long
hours, and so on.
When they're
answering in public,
they're essentially
holding back.
Which seems to suggest--
and that's consistent,
I guess, also with the
participation rates.
And that's consistent with why
there is at least a perception
of lower desirability, in
particular among their single
male peers, which is what
this results is driven by.
It's not clear, by the
way, that the study shows
that that's actually true.
That's about these
women's perceptions.
The study also
doesn't necessarily
show that this translates at
the end of the day in lower
earnings, and so
on, and so forth.
The authors argue
that that's the case.
But these are only
sort of questions--
real stakes questions and
placement questionnaires.
It's just sort of essentially
more like a proof of concept
arguing that this is
an important force that
might be at play, that
women hold themselves back
in some ways here and in
the case of a placement
questionnaire.
I had started this
already last time,
only briefly going through
the Vesterlund study, which
essentially is saying that
there's two forces going on.
There's demand [INAUDIBLE]
in terms of tasks
that women and men are
perhaps asked differently.
And beliefs could be quite
important here, and mediating
who has which tasks and when.
So let me show you a little bit
of what that study is about.
The study is essentially
asking the question
whether women are not saying
no often enough In particular
when it comes to work.
And it's motivated by the
fact those female faculty
members tend to
do a lot more what
they call non-promotable tasks.
These are tasks that essentially
everybody wants somebody
to do the task,
but they don't want
to do the tasks themselves.
So that's like essentially
University committees,
and here, also
undergraduate teaching,
or undergraduate
student advising.
Of course, everybody
loves undergrads
and wants to advise them.
However, it's not
something that's
good for peoples' career.
So at the end of the
day, faculty are often
evaluated by research output.
So any time that's spent
on committees, et cetera,
these are not going to
be helping for promotions
eventually.
And then, one first
observation is that [? women ?]
do that much more than men.
Now you might sort of
ask, why is it that women
spend their time differently?
There's potentially
issues of demand.
Women are just asked a lot
more to do these things.
And there's potentially
supply issues
conditional on being asked.
Women might be just much
more likely to say yes.
Now, what this paper argues
is that demand and supply
interact.
Because women are more
likely to say yes,
they're also more likely to
be asked in the first place.
OK.
So why do we care?
I think I already
mentioned this.
There's sort of a few
broad perspectives.
One is about, we kind
of try to understand
individual
decision-making. and we
want to understand how people
make optimal decisions.
Here's another reason
where people report.
Here is an example where people
potentially mis-optimize.
There's a managerial
social planner perspective
that if you want
to sort of organize
or you want organizations
to be efficient,
you want to make
sure that everybody
does equal work in some way.
And so you don't
want women who are
very productive to be stuck
in a bunch of other tasks
that hold them back.
And then, there's a
public policy perspective.
It might essentially
be that sex differences
and the allocation of time.
So women spending more
time on these kind of tasks
might explain why they're less
likely to be promoted and so
on.
And then, understanding that
and understanding these issues
might sort of help
with interventions
to improve equity.
Now, OK.
So what are these tasks?
Again there's promotable tasks.
That's doing research.
And there's
non-promotable tasks.
So promotable tasks,
meaning essentially,
if you do these tasks,
you're likely to be promoted
or essentially get
tenure eventually.
A non-promotable
task essentially
are tasks that many
people could do the task,
but everybody wants
somebody to do it.
But often, nobody actually
wants to do it themselves.
Now, the authors that first
[INAUDIBLE] field study
where they have faculty at
a large public University
where you send essentially
emails from a chair,
and they're requested
to volunteer
to join one of several
university-wide faculty senate
committees.
And women are essentially,
in these tasks,
are way more likely to volunteer
conditional on being asked.
So that's the first
piece of evidence
that conditional on
being asked women
are more likely to be asked.
Then you might say, well,
perhaps there's some
personality characteristic
[? it's ?] [? on. ?] Maybe
women are nicer.
Maybe women care more
about the public good.
Now, what the authors
show is that that may well
be true in some cases.
But in other cases, it's also
about expectation about who
does it and who doesn't.
Moreover, the ask
about who is asked
is quite different depending on
whether you're male or female.
And that's where the
experiment comes in.
So what they do in
an experiment is
what's called the threshold
public goods game.
It's very simple, which
is, a small group needs
to find a volunteer for a task.
These are groups of
3 people, and there's
like 10 rounds where
people are matched
over time with each other.
And so it's essentially set up
to mimic real world situations
where everyone prefers the task
to be undertaken by someone,
but not themselves.
As you don't want
to do it, you have
to have somebody else to do it.
You want that somebody
does it, but you just
don't want to do it yourself.
And so people get--
the group of 3 gets two minutes
to decide whether to invest.
And investing means
essentially you
have to [? truly ?]
press a button here.
Only one person can
invest, and the round
ends when someone invests.
If no one invests, all
the members get $1.
If you are investing you get
$1.25 and the remaining members
get $2.
So if you're thinking
about this task,
what are you thinking
about is now, A, is
somebody else going to invest?
And B, like conditional
on your beliefs about,
is somebody else going
to invest any time soon?
Do you want to invest or not?
Clearly, it's the efficient
thing that somebody invests.
But you don't want to be
yourself because then you get
only $1.25 rather than the $2.
And the clock ticks down
until one person invests,
or no investment
is made 2 minutes.
OK.
So now what do we find?
Or what did they find
in this experiment?
Women are way more likely to
invest in each of these rounds.
This is sort of
the red line here.
The blue line here is for men.
And so women are much more
likely to invest than men.
And that's very clear when
you look at these figures.
And that's also very
persistent over time.
So it's not just like, perhaps
in the first round, and so on.
This is even after 10 rounds.
When people keep being
matched with others over time,
women are much more
likely to invest.
Now, how do we interpret this?
So how do we think about this?
What can we learn about this?
One explanation that
I already mentioned
is, women are much nicer.
But can you infer
this from this task?
You observe if women are
a lot nicer than men,
well, then you should find that
women are more cooperative,
as Lucy suggests.
If women are a lot
more cooperative,
you should see that
in women-only groups,
women are much more
likely to invest
than in male-only groups.
And that's exactly what they
tried to do in the experiment.
So they have essentially
single sex sessions
would have all-female
and all-male groups.
And what you find is, while
the probability of investing
is actually exactly the
same for men and women,
they also find that
when trying to predict
who's investing who is not, any
measures of social preferences,
risk preferences and so on
that they've [? listed ?]
previously actually not
predictive of this behavior.
That sort of suggests it's
really not about altruism
in a sense of being
nicer or wanting.
So in some sense, investing
is doing something nice
for the others in your group.
It doesn't seem to be
that it's about that.
It's also not so much
about risk aversion.
So you might say, well, I'm
investing because I really
like certainty.
If I invest, I know
exactly what I'm getting.
If I'm not investing,
I have a chance
of like getting the
$2 or essentially
a lottery between $2 and
$1, depending on, then,
the probability is
essentially about what
you think is the probability
of others investing.
So your risk aversion
might matter,
but they also show that
risk aversion is really not
important.
So now they have
essentially two experiments.
One is the experiment,
1 that I showed you.
Women are more likely to
invest in mixed sex groups,
and women and men are equally
likely to invest in single sex
groups.
And so now, then,
what they're doing
is, then, they're
trying to say, well,
could it be that beliefs
that women will invest
are important here?
So that's essentially the idea.
If you think women are
more likely to invest
than men, if women think
this and men think this,
then essentially you're
going to get in a situation
where if you have
a mixed sex group,
then you will have one
woman saying to men,
the woman thinks, oh, the men
are not going to invest anyway.
So either it's like we're
investing or getting $1.
So then, for the women,
it's optimal to invest.
And the men are
going to think, well,
the woman is going to invest.
So why should they invest if
the woman is investing anyway?
For them, it's then
optimal not to invest.
Now, experiment 3,
then, get set this
in some ways, which essentially
is about now getting
women and men to ask to invest.
What they do is, essentially,
they have what's called a--
they call it a photo ask, which
they have 4 people per group.
3 people as 4 can invest.
That's essentially
the same as before.
They call them green players.
Not sure why, but they
essentially [? do ?]
[? their ?] green players.
And one person is
unable to invest,
but he can ask one of the
three others to invest.
It's not a binding request.
Essentially, it's
sort of a nudge.
So if you want to, instead
of essentially just
suggest that they may
exert some social pressure,
that's the red player.
And then, the red player is
essentially incentivized.
The red player wants the
investment to happen.
So this is kind
of what this looks
like, is essentially
three people
that you see as the red player.
And you can say,
whom would you ask?
Well, any of these three.
You see the photos,
so obviously you
see the gender of the person.
And so, what they then find
is that women are much more
likely to be asked.
You can see here, the red
lines are more to the right,
or there's more red
to the right, which
is the total times
asked to invest.
So there's more asked to the
right for women than for men.
Now, what did we
learn from that?
Well, absent a request,
investment rates
do not differ by gender.
But when asked to invest,
women are more likely to do so.
So there's two
things going on here.
One is, when asked, women
are more responsive.
And [INAUDIBLE] says that
the marginal increase
of being asked is higher
for women than for men.
And then, in addition, women are
also more likely to be asked.
Which is to say,
when people have
the choice about
whom should you ask,
well, they kind of know
who is the person who
is more likely to react, which
is the woman in the group.
So they correctly
understand that if they
ask the woman, that
it's going to have more
of an impact than asking men.
And that's true.
So when women are asked, they're
also more likely to comply.
So now, that essentially sort
of says these gender differences
get amplified by increases
for women to contribute.
So not only is it the case that
they're more likely to say yes,
but on top of that, they
also will get more requests.
Which of course, then, is like,
they do so much work overall.
And so, what's key
here is about this.
it's not about preferences.
It's essentially
just an equilibrium
that at the end of the
day will be sustained.
Because again, if men think
women are going to do it
anyway, and if
women think, well,
nobody's going to do
it unless I myself,
[? when ?] [? I ?] [? am ?] in
situations where it might be
optimal for both women
and men to do it,
conditional on
their [INAUDIBLE]..
Any questions on this study?
OK, so then, let me
just summarize a bit.
So we saw large gender wage
and earnings gaps that even
persisted even until now.
Substantial progress
has been made
due to the
technological advances
and other improvements, but
sort of those persistent gender
differences in many
societies, including the US.
Biased beliefs and
identity concerns
appear to play a particularly
important role, in particular,
in some issues such as
educational differences
and so on.
And given the
technological advances,
some of these technological
issues are less important now.
But really, it seems to be that
biased beliefs and identity
concerns are at the center of
explaining things in addition
to the child penalty.
But even the child
penalty, you might argue,
is driven by beliefs,
and identity, and so on.
And then there are these
feedback mechanisms
between demand and
supplies of tasks
that women and men are doing.
And in particular, it seems
to be that, again, beliefs
are important in the sense
of, like, it matters what
people think other people do.
And then that seems to create,
essentially, these inequalities
across gender.
Now, if you want to
sort of mitigate,
or reduce, or eliminate
the gender gap,
it's really important to
understand these issues.
I think we have made
quite a bit of progress
in understanding what's going
on, and identifying the issue.
Now, I think the next steps
are to try and understand
what are policies that are
in fact successful in helping
us do that.
So this lecture is about
defaults, nudges, and frames.
And originally, I had planned
to also do mental accounting.
But given that we
didn't finish last time,
I moved this to a later
lecture, at least [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, so where are
we in the course?
We talk a lot about preferences.
We talked a lot about beliefs
and the interaction of those,
and sort of potential deviations
from the classical model.
Now, we're going to talk about
non-standard decision-making.
And one way to think
about this is to say,
even if you understand
people's preferences very well,
then you can
understand these are
non-standard preferences
in some ways,
and potentially biased beliefs.
Even conditional on that,
people might behave in some ways
where they deviate from
the neoclassical model.
That is hard to explain just
by deviations and preferences
[INAUDIBLE].
So there are
additional deviations
from the neoclassical model
that are beyond changes
in preferences and beliefs.
In particular, I'm going to
talk now about frames, defaults,
and nudges.
Mental accounting is a
similar case of that.
We'll talk about this later.
OK, and so the most famous
paper in this space,
or one of the most
famous paper [INAUDIBLE]
is about 401(k) savings.
So companies offer
these 401(k) savings.
That's right.
So it's in fact the most common
voluntary savings vehicle
in the US.
What you do is you set aside
some money for retirement,
and you choose what's called
the contribution rate.
It's like what fraction of the
income you want to contribute,
and you choose the
asset allocation.
That is offered by
companies-- by employers.
Now, why are
employers doing this?
Because employers want to--
it's seen as sort
of a nice thing
that employers can do
for their employees.
It's potentially
a way in which you
can create some form of
solidarity with your employees.
In a way, you want
your workers to do
well in retirement beyond their
working for you, and so on.
And then, sort of overall,
what companies often do
is they offer matching
contributions up
to a threshold.
This often incentivizes that,
in fact, fairly strongly.
There's also a penalty
for early withdrawal.
Why is there a penalty
for early withdrawal?
Yeah, exactly.
It's like a soft commitment
device in some ways,
in the sense of-- or it's a hard
commitment device in the sense
that it's dominated.
But essentially, it's like you
want-- it's sort of a mixture.
You could have if like a hard
commitment, or a fully hard
commitment, or very
hard commitment device.
But you could say, you cannot
withdraw this until age 60,
or something, or 55, or
65, whenever you retire.
That's not what it is.
Instead, there's a penalty
that's often like 10%.
And the penalty is there
because you want to get people--
avoid that people--
what's called leakage,
that people essentially
withdraw money early,
presumably because
of self-control problems,
present bias, and so on.
There's lots of
leakage, in fact,
even though there's
a 10% withdrawal.
There's a 10%
withdrawal as opposed
to shutting it down entirely
because sometimes people have
shocks.
They have health
problems and so on.
They need a bunch of money.
And in those cases, of course,
you want to allow this,
or the company wants to
allow that to people.
So a 10% penalty
tends to be sort
of compromise between that.
There's tax deferral,
which is you pay,
usually, a lower marginal tax
rate during retirement, right?
When people are 30, 40
they earn a lot of money
compared to when they're
70 during retirement.
So people can pay
taxes when they receive
the money at retirement,
so to the extent
that your marginal tax
rate is lower then,
you're going to save
some money from that.
So that's another reason
why you might want
to use your 401(k) savings.
Now, what are some patterns
401(k) investments?
2/3 of employees believe that
they're saving too little
when you just ask them.
And 1/4 of these intends
to raise their savings
in the next two months.
So that's sort of the typical
thing that sort of smells
like self-control problems,
where you ask people,
like, are you happy
with your savings?
Should you be
saving more or less?
Then people tend to say, oh, no,
no, I want to really save more.
Next two months,
I'm going to do it.
This is sort of the same as when
you ask people about the gym.
I [INAUDIBLE] exercise
more every month.
But it happens.
Almost nobody follows through.
In fact, the
reported undersavers
have low savings rates.
You find similar patterns
also in other surveys.
If you're interested in more
of the Choi et al survey,
it does a very nice job at
summarizing these patterns.
Now, given these patterns,
what are standard economics
tools to increase savings?
Suppose you are
the social planner,
or a company want to
increase people's savings.
What would standard economics
1401, 14-A, or whatever
tell you what should we do
to increase people's savings?
How would you do that?
First, the matching contribution
is very much like an incentive,
so, like, a very standard,
straightforward incentive, Econ
101 would tell you people
react to incentives.
So let's give people incentives.
We provide matching
contributions, and therefore
people--
essentially increases the
rate of return on savings.
And these matching
contributions--
I'll show you in a second--
tend to be very high, or fairly
high.
And so people should
be doing it more
if you make it more
attractive [INAUDIBLE]
under usual circumstances.
What else could we do?
And maybe that's not
necessarily standard economics.
Of course, one option will
be, like, the default.
But what other options
could have or we do?
What else could we do
[INAUDIBLE] people?
Right?
So you could-- so the
matching contribution
is a way of doing that,
essentially because I'm telling
you I'm matching however much
you're contributing by adding
so much money in your
account, and you're not
supposed to withdraw it.
So that's implicitly
giving you a return.
Another thing I think
that you're already saying
is what I have
here as well, which
is provide additional choices
or better choices in some ways,
or improving what's called
our financial education.
That's to say,
maybe people are not
investing in the right thing.
And so maybe I could
either give them
better investment
funds or better options
that have higher returns.
And by doing so, people will
be inclined to save more.
Or maybe I can explain to
them better, for example,
compound interest and so
on, and sort of [INAUDIBLE]
that people don't quite
understand, perhaps
because of lower education.
Now, that's not necessarily
standard economics
in the sense of, like,
people are confused.
That's sort of not what
standard economics would say.
But it might well
be that people are--
if you explain to them better
what is compound interest,
and if you can save now 5% of
your income, how much will that
be in 30 years from
now, people are
often surprised because
that's very high.
You could sort of get them--
provide them with
additional choices,
maybe make it more
attractive for them.
You could even sort of subsidize
it and say, here's a fund,
and I'm giving you more money.
Notice that that would be
quite expensive for the company
to do over time.
So companies tend
to not do that.
Now, it turns out,
none of these tools
tend to be very effective.
So people have tried this,
despite the fact that--
they have been
matching contributions
despite the effect of
financial education, sort
of information sessions,
providing more choices,
and so on.
Notice that it actually
sometimes backfires,
because people get confused.
There's too many choices, or
what's called choice overload.
So these things tend to
not work particularly well.
Now, one question again, why
are companies actually trying
to increase people's savings?
So in some sense,
you might say, well,
we're offering-- here's
your 401(k) savings.
We'll offer it to you, but
whoever wants to actually do it
can use it.
And otherwise, we really
don't care that much.
So why are companies still
interested in doing this?
Why are people
paying this match?
We had some answer
already before,
but that's actually not
quite the answer why
this is [? going. ?]
So to be clear,
there's two questions.
One question that we talked
about a little bit previously
was, like, why might the company
offer savings options anyway?
And the second one is
conditional on offering that--
why is the company
really interested
in increasing take-up?
Because they say,
well, whatever.
We offer it.
Some people like it,
some people don't.
If they don't like
it, why do we care?
So I always thought, you know--
when I first read about this,
I thought companies are nice
and they want to sort of
be good to their employers,
and they want the best
for their workers.
And you're already a lot
more cynical in a sense of,
like, you're kind
of saying, how do we
get workers to work a lot more?
It could be.
I mean, I haven't heard
of what you were saying.
But I think in principle,
that could be a reason where--
in a way, I think companies
like workers to be happy.
And to the extent that if
they consume more right now,
that probably makes them happier
and perhaps more productive,
so then, in some
ways, probably you
have the incentives to have
people not save too much.
Because in some ways,
you don't care that
much about whether somebody
who is 60 is particularly happy
or has money.
Because essentially, you
can't really engage or you--
age discrimination is illegal.
So you can't fire, like,
a 57-year-old person who
is doing their job
reasonably well,
but maybe is not as productive
as you'd like them to be.
And so to them, if that person
has saved a lot of money,
they probably are
more likely to retire.
You guys are more
cynical than I am.
So the reported reason for
a lot of these policies
is, in fact, the reason that
there is IRS nondiscrimination
rules.
What does that mean?
Essentially, by the IRS rules,
it cannot be that people who
are paid a lot can benefit from
certain retirement and other
schemes way more than people
who are paid very little.
Now it turns out that
low income or low wage
workers are much
less likely to save
in 401(k) and other
savings schemes.
Therefore, they're much
less likely to receive
any of these 401(k) matching
and other contributions.
And therefore, essentially,
their companies
tend to have way
more money spent
on sort of high paid employees
than low paid employees.
And there are some
nondiscrimination rules
by the IRS that
says that's illegal.
You can't do that.
And therefore, companies are
very keen on getting lower--
if you are like a
CEO or something,
you want your
workers to earn very
little to invest in 401(k)
and other types of schemes
that they get rewarded
for, because that allows
them, essentially, to pay
the high paid employees
higher bonuses, in these
kinds of schemes as well.
That's essentially
one of the reasons
why companies are
very, very interested
in increasing their 401(k)
savings, in particular
among workers with low wages.
And that's exactly what the
default to default policy's
tend to do.
Chad, did you have
another question,
or was that just your
hand that's still up?
OK, so let me move on.
So why would you participate
in 401(k) savings schemes?
We already talked about this.
What are the costs
of nonparticipation?
There are essentially
three main reasons
from the worker's perspective.
There's foregone tax benefits.
And tax benefits are, again,
your marginal tax rate,
usually while
people are working,
tends to be higher than
the marginal tax rate
when people are retiring.
So essentially, by
investing in 401(k) savings,
they can defer taxes
and save some taxes.
Second, people forgo
the employer match.
I'll tell you about
this in the second.
And number three is--
that's a little
more subtle, which
is foregone consumption
smoothing, which, essentially,
is your marginal--
the marginal value
of a dollar for you,
while you're working
at age 30 or 40,
tends to be lower than the
marginal value of a dollar
once you're 70 or 80.
The reason being that,
essentially, you're richer.
You have more money available
when you're 30 or 40,
so you actually want to smooth
consumption to later in time.
Of course, there's a discounting
motive going the other way.
But it shouldn't be that,
essentially, at age 59 or 64,
you earn a lot of money
and consume a lot, and then
the year after, once you retire,
your consumption drops a lot.
Economists would say you
should smooth this out by,
essentially, saving some
money to the future.
And 401(k) savings [INAUDIBLE]
might help you with that.
Now, why do companies care?
I already said that.
Essentially-- whoops,
sorry, going back.
Non-highly compensated
employees don't save enough,
or don't save very much, in
particular in new schemes.
And the IRS
nondiscrimination tests--
has essentially
nondiscrimination tests
in pension plans that
precisely try to prevent that.
So really, what
you want to do is
you want to get your low
income workers to save.
OK, so now here comes the
paper by Madrian and Shea.
That's a very successful and one
of the most successful papers
in behavioral economics.
The reason being that, A,
standard economics has sort of
failed in some ways,
in the sense of saying,
like, we tried
matching contributions,
we tried giving people
education or information,
and so on, and so forth,
and none of these things
have worked very well.
And then instead, something
that shouldn't matter--
which is what I'm going to
show you in a second-- the
defaults mattered a lot,
and had huge effects,
which is very hard for
standard economics to explain.
And then on top of that,
this is in a domain
that we really care about a lot.
Savings is one of the
most important choices
that economists have considered.
And so that's a
very good example
of an early example of an
aspect of the economics,
in this case
default, that really
matters in some ways
that's hard to explain
for standard economics.
And the standard
tools of economics
seem to not have been
working very well.
OK, so what does the
paper actually do?
It's a large publicly-traded,
fortune 500 healthcare company.
You can enroll in 401(k)
savings plans any day
by essentially filling
out an enrollment form,
or calling the
401(k) record keeper.
What does that mean?
Essentially, you call
somebody and say,
I want you to invest
in 401(k) savings
when you're in this company.
And you're going to
say, I'm going to--
I want to save, say,
5% of my earnings.
I want to save every month.
Or you could fill out a form.
Now, these days, a
lot of this is online.
So if at MIT, you want to
change your 401(k) savings,
you essentially have to
fill out an online form,
and change your online
allocation [? potential. ?]
So there's potentially small
transaction costs involved.
But notice that the transaction
cost tends to be very minor,
in a sense, like, it's going
to take you maybe 10 minutes,
maybe 20 minutes-- maybe if
you think about it for a while,
it takes you an hour--
but really, it's a
very minor cost of time
overall that this
costs you compared
to the potentially huge benefits
of employer matches and so on.
Now, what are these
employer matches?
In this particular company,
it's a 50% matching contribution
for the first 6%.
So again, what are
these percentages?
The percentages are essentially
the fraction of your income
that you'd like to
contribute to these savings.
For example, 5% or 3%, or
7% is what you're saving.
And now the company
says they're going
to match 50% for the first 6%.
For example, if an
employee chooses 4%,
the company pays
an additional 2%
into that savings
account right away.
So that's actually
quite a bit of money.
If an employee chooses
10%, the company
pays an additional 3%,
because that employee
is above the cap of 6%.
So you cannot get more
than 3% from the company.
Other companies
these days have even,
like, 100% matching
contribution for 5% or the like.
That tends to be fairly common.
So for example, MIT has
100% matching contribution
for the first, I think, 5%.
In this specific
company, the employees
are first eligible after
one year of employment
before the change
happened of the policy
that I'm going to talk
about in a second.
Now, notice that this
is a terrible policy
from a behavioral
economics perspective,
in terms of if you wanted
people to sign up and go
do this, that's not
what you would do.
If I'm telling you, like, here's
a thing that I want you to sign
up for, in a year from now
please come back and do it,
well, in a year from
now, people might forget.
People might procrastinate.
People might be busy
with other things.
So it's not a policy that's
great to do to start with
to get people involved.
And in some sense,
there's no wonder
that participation early
on was kind of low.
Now, the company does
that because turnover
tends to be high.
And you try to
avoid paying people
early on that
might leave anyway.
And you have to deal
with the paperwork,
and so on and so forth.
Notice that that might be
exactly the wrong thing to do,
because once people have paid
into their 401(k) savings,
maybe that creates some loyalty
and makes workers to stay
more at the company anyway.
But for what it's worth,
in this particular case,
employees were only eligible
and one year after employment.
Now, then there's
a discontinuity
of the 401(k) plan default
based on the date of hire.
So here's the old cohort--
the window cohort, as I call
it-- and the new cohort.
So the old cohort are people who
are hired between 1st of April,
'96 and 31st of March, '97.
So they are essentially people
who have been previously hired.
This is what I just told you.
You can, after one year--
after being hired after
one year, you can--
you're not
automatically enrolled,
but you can essentially
just call somebody and say,
I would like to start
saving in my 401(k) savings.
Or you could fill out this form.
Then, there is the
new cohort, which
essentially is automatic
enrollment, which
is everything is exactly the
same, but by the date of hire.
So when you're
hired immediately,
you're automatically enrolled.
So they're not asking you.
They're giving you
some information,
but they say, unless
you change, unless you
want to make a
change, you're going
to be automatically
enrolled immediately.
And when you automatically
enrolled somebody,
then you need to also specify
where the money goes to.
So they have an
automatic enrollment.
You need to choose the
contribution rate, which is
the default contribution rate.
And they need to have a
default fund allocation, which
is-- so they have a default
contribution rate which is 3%.
And you need to put the
money somewhere, right?
So if I'm automatically
doing something for you
with your money, I need to
put the money somewhere.
What the company is
doing is the company
puts the money into
the money market fund.
Is that a good idea, a bad idea?
Why is the company
putting the money
into the money market fund?
Is that what you're supposed
to be doing with your savings?
[INAUDIBLE] Or
maybe first explain
what is a money market
fund, and then tell
is it a good or bad idea.
Somebody says they saw dot come
bubble coming, potentially.
But I think if you save for
retirement, what should you do?
Here's free investment
advice for everybody.
What should you do?
What are people
telling you, like,
if you go to somebody
who does finance?
[INAUDIBLE] but
essentially, what people
would argue you
should be doing is
you should invest in
stocks or some forms
of diversified
portfolio of stocks.
You should buy, essentially,
the stock market, S&P 500,
or the world stock
market, or the like,
which essentially is risky, but
also has a much higher return.
Now, given that if you started
investing at age 25 or 30,
if you do that for
30, 40 years, that
has a very likely very high
long-run return, and a much
higher long-run return
than you will have if you
invest in the money market.
Now, there's a question of what
is the optimal risk and so on.
But investing, nobody--
no investment advisor
in their right mind,
maybe perhaps partially
because they want to make money,
but I think including people
who want the best
for you will tell you
you should invest everything
and the money market.
Now why are the
companies doing that?
Essentially, the company
is worried about liability,
and about getting sued, or
getting, at least, in trouble
with their employees.
If they default--
so essentially,
if I'm not offering
any retirement savings,
then I'm like, of course,
that's not a big risk to take.
If I'm in a sense
saying, I'm hiring you,
and I'm putting your
money without really
getting explicit
consent for you,
without you explicitly
saying you want it,
and putting your money into some
investment fund, potentially
a risky investment fund, and
that thing essentially crashes,
and people lose a
lot of money, they're
going to get really upset
with you, potentially.
And that's, from the
company's perspective,
just not worth doing.
Essentially, the company
wants to help people.
Again, remember a part of
the motive of the company
was just to get people to
contribute in the first place,
to essentially get around the
IRS nondiscrimination rules.
And so the company is really
not necessarily that interested
in high returns
for their workers.
And in particular, companies
worry potentially about,
essentially, the stock
market crashing, and then
sort of people getting
really upset with them, which
would be quite costly for them.
And then they would
be, like, why did you
put the money in
this risky thing
while in fact, you could have
put it in the money market,
and so on?
And the reason
being is essentially
because there's no
explicit consent,
because it's essentially
a default option where
the default is such that
you're automatically enrolled.
So unless you tell
me otherwise, you're
going to be-- the money's
going to put there.
And so there's never
something where
the person says, yes, I want the
money to be invested in x or y.
So then, this here
is the main result
of the paper, which
is the participation
rates in 401(k) savings
accounts are dramatically
higher with automatic
enrollment compared
to the previous regime.
So you see here, this
is the old cohort.
This is the window cohort.
And these are previous cohorts.
So you see that prior
to automatic enrollment,
the participation increases--
or increased with the tenure.
That is to say, the longer
you're at the company,
the higher the
fraction of people
who participate
in 401(k) savings.
But even people who have been
in the company for 20 plus years
have only, like, a
contribution rate of about 83%.
Now, if you do automatic
enrollment, which
is getting people
enrolled-- but people
are free to choose
whatever they want.
If they don't want to invest
money into the 401(k) savings
account.
They can opt out at
any point in time.
But when you do that,
people get essentially way
more likely to be enrolled.
The participation rate
is as high as 86%.
So there are essentially
dramatic differences
in what you would argue is a
very important choice, which
is, if you think about what are
important choices in your life,
savings choice is one of
the most important ones.
So there's dramatic differences.
And when you do
automatic enrollment,
people are way more likely
to enroll than if not.
Now, in addition-- sorry.
And then this is here
is, I guess, the part
about the low income workers.
When you look at--
this is-- when you
look at the first two
columns of this table,
here you see these effects.
So first you see, this is
the window cohort here.
This is the cohort
that was essentially
before the change was done.
And here is the
new cohort, which
is the cohort that received
automatic enrollment.
The difference is dramatic
from like 37% to 86%.
And this is now by
compensation levels of workers.
And what you see here
is, in the window cohort,
you see this huge gradient
here by compensation.
So workers who are--
and this is before
the automatic enrollment.
Workers who received
fewer than $20,000
per year, only 12.5%
of them actually
were participating in 401(k)
savings to start with.
And among people who earned
a lot already anyway,
this thing was, like, 68%.
There's a huge discrepancy here.
And this is precisely where
the IRS discrimination
rules were [? fighting. ?]
Now, but if you look at
after the enrollment,
there's still-- notice that
there's still some gradient.
There's still, essentially,
like, a higher participation
rate among the high
paid employees.
But the grading is much
flatter, because essentially,
so many among the low income
workers or low wage workers
are now enrolled as well.
So there's huge effect, and the
effective is disproportionately
large among low income workers.
What are potential
reasons for that?
So they have more likely--
essentially, their
credit constraints
are more likely to bind.
Or they have a high
marginal utility of money,
and therefore, they might
be less inclined to save.
Notice that low
income workers also
have a high marginal utility
of income in the future.
So in some ways, it's
not obvious, actually,
that when you think about--
[? because when you ?] write
down a model, you think about
should you save right now
versus consume money--
so consume versus save.
You will get, essentially, what
this-- what this depends on
is the ratio of your
marginal utility right now
versus in the future.
And the marginal utility of
poor workers in the future
will also be high.
So it's not obvious that
they shouldn't be saving.
But I think it's
right that we're
saying they have
more emergencies,
and more reasons to essentially
not want the money right now.
So one thing could be just it's
mechanical in the sense of,
in some ways, it could just
be that for whatever reason,
the poor are not
saving to start with.
Maybe that's in
part due to tenure.
Maybe it's due to
some other reasons
that we don't quite understand.
But it might also be
that the poor might
be more prone to default
effects, which could be in part
what Carmen was saying.
They're sort of--
in a way, perhaps
financial sophistication,
or education,
or information-- just what's
the right thing to do--
might be lower.
And you might, as
in, like, I don't
understand what's going on.
So I'm just doing what
the company does for me
and just hope for the best.
And then you might
just go with whatever
that is, and you're less
confident in making different--
or overriding such choices.
Another explanation--
and I'm going
to talk about this when we
talk about poverty a bit--
which is the idea that poverty
taxes people's bandwidth
and attention.
That's to say,
like, essentially,
being poor is really
hard in various ways.
You have to struggle with
so many different things
about paying your bills,
and so on and so forth,
which is precisely kind
of what Jose [INAUDIBLE]
was saying in part.
Your marginal utility
of money might be high,
and you're really
concerned with that.
And you worried about
feeding your children,
and so on and so forth.
And it's just really
hard to find a time
to think about stuff carefully.
And therefore, you might,
again, sort of just
go with the default.
Because you just
don't have the bandwidth--
the mental bandwidth
to think about what's best
for you and override that.
So that's an open
question, in fact,
whether the poor are more likely
to be prone to default effects.
But I think what's almost
surely the case, or what's
been shown in various studies,
is that these effects tend
to have larger effects
among poor, low compensation
workers, which is precisely
one of the reasons
why they were so
popular overall.
OK, so then in
addition, not only
are there large effects on the
contribution decision overall.
It's like, do you want your the
participation decision overall?
Do you want to
participate versus not?
Like, do you want to contribute
any money versus not?
But also there seem to be large
effects on the contribution
rate.
That is to say, I
think I told you--
remember, I told you the default
contribution rate was 3%.
So if you were
automatically enrolled,
the company would just give
you a 3% contribution standard.
You could change that to 4%,
2%, 7%, whatever you want to do.
But the default would be 3%.
And you see, essentially,
the majority of people--
the fraction of employees
in the new cohort,
which is the automatic
enrollment, chooses 3%.
There's another thing that's
quite interesting here.
What you see is that
among people who
arguably would have chosen--
if you just look at
the window cohort,
there's some people, for
example, who chose 6%.
11% of people in
the window cohort--
that's the cohort that was
just before the automatic
enrollment--
11% of people chose 6%.
That fraction actually
goes down to 7%.
That is to say, some people
would have chosen more than 3%
in the absence of
automatic enrollment,
now they are moving down to 3%.
So there is some
effect-- there's
a bunch of mass coming
from 0% moving to 3%.
But there's also
some mass coming
from here that moves
from, essentially,
positive amounts down to 3%.
So there's sort of very
heterogeneous effect.
Some people, or
quite a few people,
increased their savings from
very low rates, or 0 rates,
to 3%.
But there's always another
other effect that, essentially,
some people who would
have sat down and done
the choice themselves,
they would have probably
chosen something like
6%, 7%, whatever,
even 15%, and some of
them have moved down to 3%
by the automatic enrollment.
So there's some negative
effect on savings
coming from that, potentially.
In addition, the asset
allocation, here,
people essentially predominantly
just choose the default.
Here you see, essentially,
the assets or stocks, bonds,
and money market.
Think about money market
essentially as like a 0%--
or a close to 0%--
very safe option.
And in the new cohort,
80% of people--
I'm not sure how well you can
see this-- but 80% of people
choose the money market,
which essentially
is exactly what the company
is choosing for them.
Well, if you have--
in the other
cohorts, this is all
conditional on participating.
The fraction who chooses stocks
and bonds is way, way higher.
And as we discussed,
the long-run return
to investing in the money
market is way, way lower.
So that's potentially,
again, another reason why--
in fact, why defaults
aren't increasing
the faction of people that
are choosing to save overall,
or to participate on
the savings overall.
The long-run savings might
not necessarily be high.
Now, let me summarize this.
I think I said,
already, most of this.
So 40% to 50% of individuals
are passive savers,
as you might want to call them.
They follow the default plan.
They essentially-- both in
terms of the participation,
but also on the contribution
rate and the asset
allocation-- they
essentially do whatever
the company chooses for them.
The suggestive choice
is not very attractive
unless it's the default.
Notice-- remember,
the window cohort.
The window cohort
were essentially
the cohort that now could just
do whatever they wanted to do.
They were told on the 1st of
April, I think, '97 or '98,
now you can invest immediately.
You can do whatever you want.
We're not choosing for you,
but you are now eligible,
even for people who have been
at the company for something
like, say, six months,
three months, and so on.
The company just made
the participation
available to anybody.
Since they had been
hired previously,
they didn't default people in.
They just made it, like, you
can change your choice now
if you wanted.
But among those people,
the window cohort
is very much looking
like the old cohort.
They're not sort of following
the company [INAUDIBLE]..
You might say, well, the
company has a new default now.
And the new default,
that's a recommendation,
so I should just follow
that default because I
don't know what to do.
That's not what
people seem to do.
So it's not like
that-- so there doesn't
seem to be that the default is a
perceived choice that's suggest
[INAUDIBLE] company, because the
window cohort really does not
follow this default or
the suggested default.
The window cohort really
looks like the old cohort.
Now, I only showed
you the results
for one company for
Madrian and Shea.
But it's a very robust result
that, if you look at the paper
by Choi et al.
that looks at this in more
detail, that finds this
over and over again in
different companies as well,
default effects tend to be
very strong in those companies.
Now one question
you might ask is,
what's explaining-- what's
the underlying reason why
these default effects
are so strong?
There are potential
candidates which
are awareness, implicit
endorsement by the company,
inattention/memory, or
potentially present bias.
And what researchers
found, it's sort of not
necessarily conclusive.
But I think the suggestive
evidence is very much that--
and particularly from
Blumenstock et al.,
that we think that
present bias might
be a quite important
reason, in addition
to the cognitive
costs of thinking
through different
savings scenarios.
So people essentially
tend to push this off
and say, oh, I'm going to
change it in the future.
At some point, I'll get to it.
I'll get to it when
it's important.
Notice that it
requires some naiveté,
because as we discussed,
if you were sophisticated,
you might of push it off
maybe a period or two.
But you would never push it
off by 10 years, or five years,
because you know you're
going to lose a lot of money.
But if you have some present
bias plus some naiveté,
you might say, well, I'm going
to do it in the future and not
right now.
And that seems to fit the
data the best, in part
because papers such as the
one by Blumenstock et al.
have ruled out some
other explanation,
for example, the
inattention/memory stories.
They set reminders.
That didn't seem
to have an effect.
They also could rule out
the implicit endorsement,
because they essentially
explicitly randomized
the people who were defaulted
in versus defaulted out.
That also had effects.
So it doesn't seem to be that.
They also made
people very clearly
aware of the different
retirement savings options.
And again, that didn't
seem to make a big effect.
So while we don't have
conclusive evidence that
present bias is sort of
causing these default defects,
in the retirement
savings choice scheme,
perhaps if I had to guess, or
if I had to say which I think is
the most likely explanation,
we think that present bias
and naiveté seem to be the
best explanations that we have
so far.
So now, one question you
might sort of say is, well,
is automatic enrollment optimal?
I showed you,
essentially, that once we
do automatic enrollment, people
are more likely to participate.
However, while they're
more likely to participate,
also these defaults seem to make
some people save less, right?
We saw some people
going essentially
from 6% participation--
contribution rate to
3% contribution rate.
They also have a much more
conservative asset allocation.
So in the long run,
it's not obvious,
in the case of this company,
whether people are actually
saving more.
Now, so how would we
answer this question?
We're going to get back to
this when we talk about policy.
But how should we
set the default?
What should we do?
What are the considerations
that we have?
And how can we decide
what's good for people?
You can essentially force
people to make a choice.
There were some companies
where, essentially, people
were very, very strongly
encouraged to-- essentially,
here's a form.
Fill it out.
Tell me what you want.
And was sort of part
of the hiring package,
and essentially was
sort of arguing--
I don't think that's
actually legal.
But it was essentially sort of
implying that one [INAUDIBLE]
to doing this form before
you can start working,
and otherwise, you can't
start working at this company.
And now, we can look at,
like, what are people
actually choosing when
everybody chooses actively?
And that's presumably when
people are paying attention,
or maybe people do the best
they can for their choices,
and they're not
automatically enrolled
either in 0%, or 3%,
or other percentages.
And so this paper
for by Carroll et al.
looks attractive choices.
And when people
choose actively, they
look a lot like the new
cohort in Madrian and Shea.
So essentially,
that's sort of seems
to say that the default
did in fact-- the default
into automatic enrollment
seemed to have alleviated
undersavings.
Because when people
choose actively,
they choose a lot-- look
a lot like the new cohort
compared to the old cohort.
It seems to be that
people, when they're
defaulted in the no savings
option, they kind of maybe
think, oh, I'll do it in the
future, and so on and so forth.
But then they never
sort of get to it.
Now, when you actually ask
them actually what you want,
it seems like people are
mostly wanting to enroll.
Now, one thing that
is quite interesting
here is that it seems like the
default effects seem to mostly
disappear after three years.
That's true for
quite a few studies.
However, even if
that's the case,
well, there's no catch-up
in levels, right?
So if you start contributing
after three years, while you
miss out on three
years of savings,
you're never going
to catch up overall.
Moreover, people tend to
change their employers
very frequently,
particularly in the US.
So if it takes you only--
if it takes you three years to
sign up for retirement savings
every time you
switch your employer,
you're going to
not save very much.
Chetty et al had an example
where they find, in fact,
very clear effects on long-run
savings of these types
of default [INAUDIBLE].
Now, let me tell you a
little bit now about--
I'm going to sort of move
the frames and nudges
until next time, which I think
should be fine because there's
not that much left anyway.
But let me tell you a little
bit about a cautionary tale
about defaults.
This is a paper by-- a very
short paper by Cronqvist
and Thaler that looks
at the privatization
of social security in Sweden.
So they had 456 funds.
And there was one default
fund chosen by the government.
And in 2000, this
default fund was
discouraged with a massive
marketing campaign.
Essentially people said, like,
don't choose the default fund.
Just pick for yourself.
Make the choice that's
the best for you.
And then in 2003, this
marketing campaign ended.
And now essentially,
the majority, again,
sort of chose the
default account or fund.
Now, as it happens, the
portfolios actively chosen
in 2000 did a lot
worse than the default.
So people, essentially,
were choosing on their own.
And in part, I think because
they're just unlucky,
because it happened to be at the
wrong time and the wrong place,
chose sort of very risky assets.
And the default tended to be
somewhat more conservative.
So people lost a lot of money.
So now, that's the
more general issue
is that active choice is less
attractive if consumers are
less financially sophisticated.
Again, in the Cronqvist
and Thaler case,
maybe they were just unlucky.
But in general, if you want
people to choose actively
and they don't know
what they're doing,
well, then they're going
to be potentially worse.
There is similar
evidence, for example,
for health care insurance
choices, where people just
don't know what health insurance
choice is best for them.
So you can give
them more options,
they might be potentially
doing worse, because they just
don't know what to do.
And then they choose
options that are worse,
and they're more likely, for
example, to be exploited.
And then, having a default
choice that is perhaps not
optimal for everybody, but it's
pretty conservative and pretty
good for most people, might
be, in fact, quite valuable.
And so now, when
you think about,
like, optimal
decision regimes, when
you think of an active
choice versus default,
consumer heterogeneity makes
active choice more attractive.
If you think people want
very different things,
and they know about
what's best for them,
and we don't have
that information--
we don't know what's good for
some people versus others--
well, it's best to let
people choose on their own.
Let's let them pick
what's good for them,
and then they'll be happy.
But active choice only
improves the outcome
if people actually know
what's good for them.
If everybody is
confused and doesn't
know what they're
doing, well then,
letting people choose
actively will potentially
make things worse for
quite a few people.
And so you want to make sure
that defaults don't make people
worse off.
This is what Jose was saying.
In particular, people
might sort of oversave
if you default them
into high savings.
And then they have credit
card debt or other sort
of problems arising from that.
So we want to be quite careful.
One option one can try and do
is try to provide information
sessions and make sure
people know, here's--
or trying to sort of provide
a curated set of three, four
options that we think
are good options
for different types of people,
provide information for them,
make sure they
understand these options,
and that then people
choose on their own.
Another popular alternative--
I'm going to talk about this
a little bit when we
talk about policy--
which is called the
smart plan, or, like,
auto-escalation plans, which are
essentially more like automatic
raises in the future,
where you essentially
can commit to
automatically raising
your savings in the future.
You say, essentially, every
time I get a pay raise, 1%,
or some fraction
of that pay raise,
or one percentage point of my
earnings of that pay raise,
will go through my savings.
So then, you don't
have to reduce
your consumption or your salary
right now that you receive,
but in the future.
That's good.
In particular, it addresses
present bias and loss aversion.
Because people are really averse
to reducing their paycheck
right now, and for present
bias and loss aversion reasons.
When I was asking
about information
versus financial education,
I mean kind of both of those.
You can find information about
what are these options, what's
good about this investment
option versus another,
and so providing
financial education,
but in particular, financial
education plus active choice.
Essentially, by
active choice, I mean
pushing people really
to choose, and saying,
look, what do you want?
Do you want option A,
which is no retirement
savings, or option B, which is
like 3%, or 6%, or whatever.
The current format is more--
essentially, is,
like, no information,
and the default is
essentially 0 savings.
And then, you have to
actively choose on your own
as an employer.
And many employees--
sorry, as an employee.
Many employees just don't know
what to do, and get confused.
And then they get frazzled,
and then procrastinate it,
and then never do it, perhaps
in part because of confusion.
OK, and then other settings
have enormous before the fact.
This is, for example,
true for organ donations.
I talked about this already in
the first or second lecture.
There's some other settings
such as voter registration,
green energy options, and so on.
So default effects can be
really, really powerful.
But one wants to be quite
careful in using them.
I'm going to talk
about this a little bit
at the end of this
lecture next time.
Let me stop here.
Let me just tell you what to
read, which is-- one second--
which is the paper by Ariely et
al., sections one through four.
You can read more if you want,
but section one through four
already gets you pretty far.
This is really a fun
paper that questions
a lot of assumptions of
neoclassical economics,
makes you wonder where
preferences come from
and what they really mean.
So it's a fun read.
I'll talk about this in
the remaining part of this
lecture-- which is a bit
on frames and nudges--
more generally next
time on Wednesday.
Let me know if you
have any questions.
Thank you so much.